.
THEIR MURDERS SHOCKED THE SMALL
COLLEGE TOWN AN THE COUNTRY,
THIS PRESSER BEGINS RIGHT NOW.
>>> THANK YOU FOR COMING TODAY.
LAST NIGHT THE CON JEKS WITH THE
PENNSYLVANIA STATE POLICE AND
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION AND DETECTIVES
ARRESTED 28-YEAR-OLD BRIAN
CHRISTOPHERCOBERGER IN ALL
BRIGHTSVILLE, PENNSYLVANIA, FOR
THE MURDER OF ETHAN, ZANA AND
MADISON AND KAYLEE.
I WANT TO THANK THESE AGENCIES
FOR THIS ASSISTANCE IN THIS
CASE.
HE RESIDE THE IN PULLMAN,
WASHINGTON AND IS A STUDENT AT
WASHINGTON STATE FLUF.
WE'LL PROVIDE AS MUCH
INFORMATION AS WE CAN ABOUT THE
EXTRADITION TO IDAHO AND THE
CRIMINAL PROCESS.
HOWEVER, DUE TO IDAHO STAY LAW
WE ARE LIMITED IN WHAT
INFORMATION WE COULD RELEASE
TODAY UNTIL HE HAS HAD HIS
INITIAL APPEARANCE IN IDAHO
COURT.
I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
APPRECIATION TO OUR LOCAL
COMMUNITY.
THE PEOPLE OF IDAHO AND THOSE
THROUGHOUT OUR NATION WHO
PROVIDED INFORMATION TO HELP US
INVESTIGATE THESE MURDERS HAS
BEEN VERY IMPRESSIVE.
WE'VE RECEIVED OVER 19,000 TIPS
AND WE'VE CONDUCTED OVER 300
INTERVIEWS.
TO RECAP THIS CASE, ON THE
EVENING OF NOVEMBER 12th, KAYLEE
AND MADISON ARRIVED HOME AT
ABOUT 1:56 A.M.
AFTER VISITING A LOCAL BAR AND
STREET FOOD VENDOR.
ETHAN AND ZANA WERE AT THE SIGMA
HOUSE BEFORE ARRIVING HOME
AROUND 1:45 A.M.
THE TWO SURVIVING ROOMMATES
RETURNED AROUND 1:00 A.M.
ON THE MORNING OF NOVEMBER 13th,
A 911 CALL WAS MADE AT 11:58
A.M. REPORTING AN UNCONSCIOUS
PERSON AT THE RESIDENCE.
THE CALL CAME IN, THE CALL CAME
FROM INSIDE OF THE HOME FROM ONE
OF THE SURVIVING ROOMMATES' CELL
PHONES.
MOSCOW POLICE RESPONDED AND
FOUND TWO VICTIMS ON THE SECOND
FLOOR, AND TWO VICTIMS ON THE
THIRD FLOOR.
ON NOVEMBER 17th, AUTOPSIES WERE
CONDUCTED AND THE LATA COUNTY
CORONER CONFIRMED THE IDENTITY
OF THE FOUR VICTIMS AND THE
CAUSE AND MANNER OF DEATH WAS
HOMICIDE BY STABBING.
SOME HAD DEFENSIVE WOUNDS AND
EACH HAD MULTIPLE -- EACH HAD
BEEN STABBED MULTIPLE TIMES.
THESE MURDERS HAVE SHAKEN OUR
COMMUNITY AND NO ARREST WILL
EVER BRING BACK THESE YOUNG
STUDENTS.
HOWEVER, WE DO BELIEVE JUSTICE
WILL BE FOUND THROUGH THE
CRIMINAL PROCESS.
THIS WAS A VERY COMPLEX AND
EXTENSIVE CASE.
WE DEVELOPED A CLEAR PICTURE
OVER TIME, AND WE STAND ASSURED
THAT THE WORK WAS NOT -- THE
WORK IS NOT DONE, BE ASSURED THE
WORK IS NOT DONE.
THIS IS JUST STARTING.
SINCE NOVEMBER, WE HAVE REMAINED
LASER FOCUSED ON PURSUING EVERY
LEAD IN OUR PURSUIT OF JUSTICE
FOR THE VICTIMS AND THEIR
FAMILIES.
I RECOGNIZE THE FRUSTRATION WITH
THE LACK OF INFORMATION THAT HAS
BEEN RELEASED.
HOWEVER, PROVIDED ANY DETAILS IN
THIS CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
MIGHT HAVE TAINTED THE UPCOMING
CRIMINAL PROSECUTION OR ALERTED
THE SUSPECT OF OUR PROGRESS.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE AS
MUCH INFORMATION AS WE CAN AS
THE PROCESS MOVES FORWARD.
TODAY, I WANT TO SPECIFICALLY
THANK OUR DEDICATED MOSCOW
POLICE DEPARTMENT DETECTIVES,
PATROL OFFICERS, THE IDAHO STATE
DETECTIVES, THE IDAHO STATE
TROOPERS AND THEIR CRIME LAB
TECHNICIANS AND SCIENTISTS FOR
THE RESOURCES PERSONNEL TO
CONDUCT THIS MASSIVE
INVESTIGATION. IT WAS THE
DEDICATION OF THEM AND THE
PERSISTENCE AND THE NUMEROUS
HOURS THAT LED TO AN ARREST.
FORTUNATELY THESE HIGHLY SKILLED
PEOPLE WORKED TOGETHER AS A
COHESIVE TEAM TO SOLVE THIS
CASE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
COMMUNITY, AND THE NATION OVER
THE PAST SIX WEEKS I'VE BEEN
CONTINUALLY REMINDED OF HOW MUCH
OUR COMMUNITY CARES.
LOCALLY PUBLIC SUPPORT HAS BEEN
EXCEPTIONAL WITH KIND WORDS,
FOOD FOR INVESTIGATORS, AND
LETTERS OF SUPPORT.
YOU WILL NEVER KNOW HOW MUCH
YOUR WORDS OF ENCOURAGEMENT
HELPED US THROUGH THESE TRYING
TIMES.
I APPRECIATE EACH OF YOU, AND
EACH OF YOUR KINDNESS.
AGENCIES AND INDIVIDUALS FROM
ACROSS THE NATION HAVE REACHED
OUT TO US, TO EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT TO THIS DEPARTMENT.
I'M REMINDED HOW OUR MOSCOW
COMMUNITY, OUR FAMILIES AND THE
NATION HAS BEEN IMPACTED BY THIS
DAILY.
FINALLY, I DO WANT TO THANK OW
MEDIA PARTNERS FOR THE HELP.
YOU KEPT THIS IN THE NEWS, YOU
HELPED US WITH TIPS, YOU KEPT
THINGS GOING AND WE TRULY
APPRECIATE THAT.
AND YOU ARE THE PRODUCT OF THOSE
19,000 TIPS THAT WE RECEIVED.
WHICH IS AN IMPRESSIVE NUMBER.
I WOULD LIKE TO INVITE BILL
THOMPSON, THE COUNTY PROSECUTOR
UP AT THIS TIME.
>> GOOD AFTERNOON, FOLKS.
MY NAME IS BILL THOMPSON, I'M
THE LATA COUNTY PROSECUTOR AND
IT IS SAD TO BE HERE BUT HAPPY
TO HERE AT THE SAME TIME.
A CRIMINAL COMPLAINT WAS FILED
YESTERDAY HERE IN LATAH COUNTY,
CHARGING MR. COEBERGER WITH FOUR
COUNTS OF MURDER IN ADDITION TO
FELONY BURGLARY.
LET ME REFACE, THERE IS A
PENDING CASE NOW IN COURT AND I
AND ANY OFFICE AND THE
INVESTIGATORS HAVE TO LIVE WITH
THE RESTRICTIONS THAT OUR
SUPREME COURT PLACES ON PRETRIAL
PUBLICITY.
THAT SAID, I PROMISE YOU WE WILL
SHARE WITH YOU THROUGH THE COURT
PROCESS OR OTHERWISE WE ARE
ALLOWED TO.
I APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE ON
THAT.
THE FACTUAL BASIS FOR THE
CHARGES ARE SUMMARIZED IN WHAT
IS CALLED A PROBABLE CAUSE
AFFIDAVIT, THAT IS ON FILE WITH
THE COURT.
ACCORDING TO THE RULES OF THE
IDAHO SUPREME COURT, THAT IS
SEALED UNTIL MR. COEBERGER IS
SERVED WITH THE IDAHO ARREST
WARRANT.
AT THAT TIME WE EXPECT THAT THAT
AFFIDAVIT WILL BE AVAILABLE TO
YOU SO YOU COULD SHARE THE TRUE
FACTS WITH ALL OF YOUR READERS
AND YOUR WATCHERS AND YOUR
LISTENERS AND ALL OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE INTERESTED IN REALLY
NEED TO KNOW WHAT IS GOING ON.
SO HAVE PATIENCE WITH US ON
THAT.
WE HOPE TO GET THAT TO YOU AS
SOON AS WE CAN.
AS FAR AS MR. COEBERGER, HE'S A
GRADUATE STUDENT FROM WASHINGTON
STATE UNIVERSITY AND HAS AN IF
APARTMENT OVER IN PULLMAN.
HE IS HAS AN INITIAL APPEARANCE
IN FRONT OF A JUDGE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
HE'S BEEN HELD WITHOUT BOND.
AND THE WARRANT FROM OUR
MAGISTRATE JUDGE HERE ALSO
PROVIDED FOR NO BOND.
WE UNDERSTAND THAT HE'S
SCHEDULED TO BE BACK IN COURT IN
PENNSYLVANIA NEXT TUESDAY
AFTERNOON.
AND THE PUBLIC DEFENDER HAS BEEN
APPOINTED FOR HIM THERE.
THE PROCESS AT THIS POINT IS
SINCE HE WAS ARRESTED IN ANOTHER
STATE, HE HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
EITHER WAIVE EXTRADITION AND
RETURN VOLUNTARILY TO THE STATE
OF IDAHO, OR IF HE PREFERS NOT
TO WAIVE EXTRADITION, WE WILL
INITIATE EXTRADITION PROCEEDINGS
THROUGH YOUR GOVERNOR'S OFFICE.
IF WE DO THAT, IT COULD TAKE A
WHILE FOR HIM TO GET HERE.
SO AGAIN, I'M ASKING FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AND UNDERSTAND THAT IS
JUST THE WAY THE SYSTEM WORKS.
ONCE HE GETS HERE, HE'LL HAVE AN
INITIAL APPEARANCE WITH OUR
MAGISTRATE, THEY'LL DEAL WITH
ISSUES SUCH AS MAKING SURE
COUNSEL IS -- COMPETENT COUNSEL
IS SCHEDULED.
YOUR PRIMARY SOURCE OF FACTUAL
INFORMATION IS THE COURT RECORD
BECAUSE THAT IS WHAT THE SUPREME
COURT SAID WE NEED TO REFER YOU
TO.
SO, PLEASE, PAY ATTENTION TO
WHAT IS GOING ON IN COURT AND
HAVE PEOPLE THERE TO WATCH AND
HEAR WHAT IS BEING SAID.
AS AN ATTORNEY, MYSELF AND MY
OFFICE, WE ARE LIMITED ON WHAT
WE ARE ALLOWED BY THE COURTS TO
SAY OUTSIDE OF THE COURTROOM.
SO PLEASE JUST WORK WITH US.
FINALLY, AS THE CHIEF INDICATED,
THIS IS NOT THE END OF THIS
INVESTIGATION.
IN FACT, THIS IS A NEW
BEGINNING.
YOU ALL KNOW THE NAME OF THE
PERSON WHO HAS BEEN CHARGED WITH
THESE OFFENSES.
PLEASE GET THAT INFORMATION OUT
THERE.
PLEASE ASK THE PUBLIC, ANYONE
WHO KNOWS ABOUT THIS INDIVIDUAL,
TO COME FORWARD, CALL THE TIP
LINE, REPORT ANYTHING YOU KNOW
ABOUT HIM TO HELP THE
INVESTIGATORS AND EVENTUALLY OUR
OFFICE AND THE COURT SYSTEM
UNDERSTAND FULLY THERE IS TO
KNOW ABOUT NOT ONLY THE
INDIVIDUAL, BUT WHAT HAPPENED
AND WHY.
NEXT I WILL INTRODUCE COLONEL
KED WELLS FROM THE IDAHO STATE
POLICE.
THANK YOU.
>> WELL GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS KEDRIC WILLS.
I SERVE AS DIRECTOR OF THE IDAHO
STATE POLICE AND WANT TO EXTEND
OUR APPRECIATION FOR YOUR
PRESENCE HERE TODAY.
THESE TRAGIC MURDERS TOOK FOUR
YOUNG VIBRANT LIVES TO OUR
COMMUNITY AND THE ONLY THING
THAT WE COULD DO IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HONOR THEIR
MEMORIES IS TO BRING THIS TO A
SUCCESSFUL CONCLUSION.
THIS IS BEEN A VERY DIFFICULT
TIME FOR THE FAMILIES, THE
UNIVERSITY, THE COMMUNITY AND
THE STATE OF IDAHO.
HOWEVER, IT IS ALSO PROVEN THAT
COMMUNITIES COME TOGETHER IN
TOUGH TIMES.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OF THE LOCAL COMMUNITY AND OUR
NATIONAL AUDIENCE THAT HAS BEEN
FOLLOWING US AS WE WORK -- OUR
INVESTIGATORS HAVE WORKED
THROUGH THIS CASE.
I'M THANKFUL ALSO TO YOU, THE
MEDIA PARTNERS, WHO HAVE HELPED
KEEP THIS CASE IN THE FOREFRONT
THAT GENERATES THE TIPS AND
CONTINUES WHAT WE HOPE WILL
CONTINUE TO GENERATE INFORMATION
THAT WILL HELP US TO A
CONCLUSION OF THIS PROCEEDING.
I'D LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR
APPRECIATION ON BEHALF OF THE
IDAHO STATE POLICE TO CHIEF FRY
AND HIS LEADERSHIP AN THE ENTIRE
MOSCOW POLICE DEPARTMENT FOR THE
WAY THEY HANDLED THIS FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING.
HE DIRECTED THE RIGHT PEOPLE, TO
THE RIGHT POSITIONS THAT LED US
TO THIS CONCLUSION TODAY.
I'VE HAD THE UTMOST CONFIDENCE
IN THIS INVESTIGATION AND IN
CHIEF FRY AS WELL AS IN MR. BILL
THOMPSON AND THE LATA COUNTY
PROSECUTORS OFFICE WHO HAVE BEEN
A GREAT PARTNER.
NOTHING HAS DEERETERRED THE
COMMITMENT OF THE INVESTIGATORS
WORKING ON THE CASE REGARDLESS
OF THE ORGANIZATION THEY
REPRESENT.
IT IS VERY TRYING AND DIFFICULT
AS YOU KNOW THAT IT HAS BEEN ON
THOSE INVESTIGATORS AS THEY DO
THE TEDIOUS WORK THAT THEY'RE SO
GOOD AT DOING.
THE PARTNERSHIPS IS WHAT IS LED
HERE AS WELL.
THE PARTNERSHIPS BETWEEN MOSCOW
POLICE DEPARTMENT, I'D LIKE TO
EXPRESS OUR APPRECIATION WITH
THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION, SPECIFICALLY THE
SPECIAL AGENT IN CHARGE OUT OF
THE SALT LAKE CITY DIVISION,
DENNIS RICE AND IN THE LAST 24
HOURS WITH THE PENNSYLVANIA
STATE POLICE AND COLONEL EVAN,
WE APPRECIATE WHAT THEY'VE DONE
ACROSS THE NATION TO HELP US AS
WELL.
AS BILL SHARED, THIS
INVESTIGATION IS FAR FROM OVER.
IN FACT, I APPRECIATE WHAT HE
SHARED THAT IT IS NOT AN ENDING
BUT RATHER A NEW BEGINNING.
THE DIFFERENCE NOW IS, AS HE
SHARED, THAT WE'RE DICTATING
WHAT INFORMATION WE COULD SHARE
BY THE COURTS OF IDAHO AND AS HE
SHARED, MR. THOMPSON IS
ABSOLUTELY COMMITTED TO SHARE
EVERYTHING THAT HE CAN SHARE
THROUGH THE COURT PROCESS.
WE'VE GOT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T GET IN FRONT OF THAT
PROCESS.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE DEEPLY,
APPRECIATE THE RELATIONSHIPS
THAT WERE FORGED HERE THAT HAVE
LED TO THIS AND BASED ON THAT,
IT IS WHY WE'RE HERE TODAY.
AND WE CONTINUE TO BELIEVE THAT
THE BEST WAY WE COULD HONOR
THESE FOUR LIVES THAT HAVE BEEN
TAKEN IS TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE A SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME HERE.
ONE OF THE PARTNERSHIPS THAT HAS
BEEN FORGED IS A PARTNERSHIP
WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO AND
ON THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO, MR. SCOTT
GREEN.
>> THANK YOU, GOOD AFTERNOON.
SCOTT GREEN.
PRESIDENT OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
IDAHO.
TODAY'S NEWS AND ARREST IS A
WELCOME ONE.
IT IS A RELIEF TO OUR
UNIVERSITY.
OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR EXTENDED
FAMILY.
THE OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT OVER
THE PAST SIX WEEKS HELPED
SUSTAIN US DURING THE MOST
TRYING TIME.
THEY PROVIDE THE STRENGTH THAT
HELPED US NAVIGATE THE
INTERNATIONAL SCRUTINY, VISITED
ON OUR STUDENTS AND EMPLOYEES.
WE ARE TRULY THANKFUL FOR THE
COMPASSION AND ACTS OF KINDNESS
SLOAN TO OUR COMMUNITY.
KINDNESS IS CONTAGIOUS AND IT
PROVIDED THE LIGHT THAT
RECLAIMED GROUND LOST TO EVIL
AND DARKNESS.
WE FIRST WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE AND
THANK GOVERNOR LITTLE FOR THE
EARLY PROMISE OF FINANCIAL
SUPPORT THAT ENABLED THE
UNIVERSITY TO SECURE OUR CAMPUS
AND FOCUS ON HELPING OUR
STUDENTS AND OUR EMPLOYEES IN
THE WAKE OF THE CRIMES.
WE ALSO APPRECIATE THE IDAHO
STATE POLICE AND THE HIGHLY
VISIBLE SECURITY PRESENCE THAT
BROUGHT COMFORT AND CALM TO
COMMUNITY SHOCKED AND CONFUSED
BY THE SENSELESS CRIMES.
WE NEVER LOST FAITH THAT THIS
CASE COULD BE SOLVED AND ARE
GRATEFUL FOR THE HARD WORK OF
THE MOSCOW POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
THEIR LAW ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS.
THE VAST AND COMMITTED FBI
RESORTS BROUGHT IMPORTANT
EXPERTISE TO THIS COMPLEX CASE.
ACROSS THE BOARD, DEDICATED
PERSONNEL WORKED THIS CASE TO
ARREST.
THIS CRIME HAS NEVERTHELESS LEFT
A MARK ON OUR UNIVERSITY, OUR
COMMUNITY, AND OUR STATE.
WHILE WE CANNOT BRING BACK
MADDY, KAYLEE AND ZANA AND
ETHAN, WE COULD CARRY THEIR
LEGACY IN THE WORK THAT WE DO.
OUR STUDENTS COME FIRST AND THAT
WAS PROVEN EACH AND EVERY DAY OF
THIS INVESTIGATION.
WE'RE COMMITTED TO SAFELY
DELIVERING THE COLONEL TOWN
ATMOSPHERE AND HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION FOR THIS THE
UNIVERSITY OF IDAHO IS KNOWN.
WITH TIME WE WILL HEAL, AND
WE'LL MOVE FORWARD TOGETHER AND
REMAIN VANDAL STRONG.
AND WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
TURN IT BACK OVER TO CHIEF FRY.
>> SO WE WE WILL OPEN THE FLOOR
TO QUESTIONS HOWEVER I WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE, AS PROSECUTOR
BILL THOMPSON EXPLAINED, ANY
FACTUAL INFORMATION REGARDING
THE ARREST OF KOHBERGER IS SEAL
AND WILL NOT BE RELEASED UNTIL
HE'S APPEARED IN AN IDAHO COURT.
PLEASE FORMULATE YOUR QUESTIONS
ACCORDINGLY.
I REALIZE THERE ARE A LOT OF
QUESTIONS AND I'LL TRY TO ANSWER
AS MANY OF THEM AS I CAN.
>> LAUREN PATTERSON, NORTHWEST
PUBLIC BROADCASTING, SPOKE AB AN
PUBLIC RADIO.
I'M NOT INTO FAMILIAR WITH HOW
IT WORKS BUT WHAT TIP, WHAT
LEAD, WHAT PIECE OF EVIDENCE
REALLY LED YOU ALL THE WAY FROM
IDAHO TO THE SUSPECT IN
PENNSYLVANIA?
>> AS I'VE SAID IN THE PAST,
THAT IS PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
AND WE WON'T BE RELEASING THAT
AT THIS TIME.
WE WILL HAVE THOSE ANSWERS,
WE'LL HAVE THEM AS SOON AS WE
COULD MAKE THOSE AVAILABLE TO
YOU.
>> AND A QUICK FOLLOW-UP AND A
TWO-PARTER.
IS OUR COMMUNITY SAFE OR IS THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT STILL ON THE
SEARCH FOR OTHER SUSPECTS MIGHT
BE INVOLVED IN THIS ATTACK.
>> WE HAVE AN INDIVIDUAL IN
CUSTODY.
WHO COMMITTED THESE HORRIBLE
CRIMES.
AND I DO BELIEVE OUR COMMUNITY
IS SAFE.
BUT WE STILL NEED TO BE
VIGILANT.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS IN THE
PAST.
WE ALWAYS NEED TO BE AWARE OF
OUR SURROUNDINGS AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE'RE AWARE OF WHAT IS
GOING ON.
>> CHIEF, HI, CHIEF.
HOW SOON INTO THE INVESTIGATION
DID POLICE AND LAW ENFORCEMENT
BEGIN TO SPOT MR. COEBERGER AND
HOW MANY TIPS WERE SPECIFICALLY
RELATED TO MR. COEBERGER.
>> TO THE TIP PART, I CAN'T
ANSWER THAT QUESTION SO I WON'T
SPECULATE.
AND THAT IS PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATION AND IT WILL COME
OUT.
I'D LIKE THE MIC TO PLEASE COME
RIGHT OVER HERE.
>> THANK YOU.
DANA GRIFFIN WITH NBC NEWS.
CAN YOU CONFIRM THAT HE ASKED
WHETHER OR NOT ANYONE ELSE HAS
BEEN ARRESTED WHEN HE WAS THERE
CUSTODY?
>> I CANNOT CONFIRM THAT OR --
I'M NOT SURE OF THAT INFORMATION
BUT THAT WOULD STILL BE PART OF
OUR INVESTIGATION.
>> DID CODE US RETURN ANY HITS
ON THIS GUY.
>> THAT IS PART OF OUR
INVESTIGATION.
>> AND THEN ONE FINAL QUESTION.
IS THERE ANY MESSAGE TO THE
ONLINE SLEUTHS WHO SLANDERED AND
HARASSED PEOPLE WHO THEY
BELIEVED WERE RESPONSIBLE?
>> THERE WAS A LOT OF
SPECULATION GOING ON.
AND WE'VE ALWAYS SAID FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING THAT WE'RE THE
OFFICIAL MESSAGE THAT COMES OUT
AND TO PAY ATTENTION TO WHAT
WE'RE PUTTING OUT THERE TO THE
PRESS.
>> I'M NANCY LIEU WITH NEWS
NATION AND WE'RE OVER AT THE
HOUSE THIS MORNING AND YOU TOLD
US THAT THE REMEDIATION WOULD
BEGIN TODAY.
IT WAS SUDDENLY STOPPED.
CAN YOU TELL US WHY?
>> YES.
THE HOUSE CLEAN-UP HAS BEEN
HALTED AND THAT CAME BY A LEGAL
REQUEST FROM THE COURT.
>> CHRISTINA CORBIN, FOX NEWS.
CHIEF, HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED A
MOTIVE.
>> THAT IS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND THAT WILL COME
OUT AS WE CONTINUE THE
INVESTIGATION.
BUT WHAT WE STILL ASK IS FOR
PEOPLE TO CONTINUE TO SEND US
THINGS IN THE TIP LINE.
WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR MORE
INFORMATION, WE'RE STILL TRYING
TO BUILD THAT PICTURE JUST LIKE
WE HAVE STATED ALL ALONG.
WE'RE PUTTING ALL OF THE PIECES
TOGETHER AND THAT WILL HELP.
>> CHIEF, VERONICA MIRACLE WITH
CNN.
ANY INDICATION THAT THE SUSPECT
KNEW THE VICTIMS?
>> THAT IS PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION AS WELL.
IT WOULDN'T BE SOMETHING THAT
WILL COME OUT AT THIS POINT IN
TIME BUT AS WE CONTINUE THIS
INVESTIGATION AND AS THIS CASE
GOES TO TRIAL, THAT WILL BE
BROUGHT FORTH.
>> YOU HAVE SPOKEN TO THE
FAMILIES?
CAN YOU TELL US WHAT THEY'VE
TOLD YOU TODAY?
>> ARE YOU TALKING THE VICTIMS'
FAMILIES?
>> YES.
>> WE HAVE REACHED OUT TO THE
VICTIMS FAMILIES, WE'VE DONE
THAT DAILY AND WE'VE CONTINUED
TO HAVE CONTACT WITH THEM.
>> NATE SANFORD, YOU MENTIONED
THAT YOU'RE STILL SEEING TIPS
ABOUT BRYAN AND THAT PEOPLE
SHOULD STILL SHARE INFORMATION.
YOU COULD SPEAK ABOUT WHAT
SPECIFIC PEOPLE SHOULD BE
REACHING OUT FOR, IF THEY KNOW
SOMETHING.
>> I WOULD SAY ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING.
AS WE'VE SAID AALL ALONG, WE
KNOW WHAT TIPS WE'RE LOOKING
FOR.
WE'LL TAKE THOSE TIPS AND WE'LL
HAVE PROFESSIONALS LOOK AT THOSE
AND DECIDE WHICH PIECES WE NEED
TO USE FOR OUR CASE SO WE ASK
THAT EVERYBODY WOULD DO THAT.
>> ANGELA, IDAHO STATESMAN.
YOUR DEPARTMENT AND OTHER
INVESTIGATORS ON THE CASE TOOK A
LOT OF FLACK FOR KEEPING
INFORMATION CLOSE TO YOUR K4E69.
ARE YOU GLAD THAT YOU DID THAT
AND WERE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
TIPPING THE SUSPECT OFF.
>> I WILL 100% STAND BEHIND THE
WAY WE HANDLED THIS
INVESTIGATION AND THIS IS ALL
STARTED FROM DAY ONE WITH OUR
PATROL OFFICERS ARRIVING ON
SCENE, LOCKING DOWN THE POLICE
AND CALLING IN THE POLICE AND
THE FBI AND KEEPING INFORMATION
THAT WAS PERTINENT TO THIS CASE
VERY, VERY TIGHT.
WE WANT TO HAVE A SITUATION
WHERE WHEN THIS GOES TO TRIAL,
THERE IS TO DOUBT THAT WE'VE
DONE EVERYTHING RIGHT AND WE'VE
SLOWED DOWN AND WE'VE CONTINUED
TO SLOW DOWN AND WE'LL CONTINUE
TO DO THAT.
>> HEY, CHIEF.
HAVE YOU GUYS FOUND THE MURDER
WEAPON OR THE HYUNDAI ELANTRA.
>> WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR ALL
PIECES OF EVIDENCE.
BUT WE ARE STILL LOOKING FOR
THE WEAPON.
AND I WILL SAY THAT WE HAVE
FOUND AN ELANTRA.
>> STEPHANIE BECKER WITH CNN.
CAN YOU TELL WHAT IT WAS LIKE
WHEN YOU GET THE PHONE CALL WHEN
THE POLICE TOLD YOU THAT THEY
HAD YOUR SUSPECT?
>> I COULD TELL YOU FOR A LOT OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT IT WAS A FAIRLY
SLEEPLESS COUPLE OF DAYS WITH,
AS WE WERE LEADING UP TO
EVERYTHING THAT THEY WERE DOING.
BUT WHAT I COULD TELL YOU IS
THAT I HAVE FAITH IN THOSE
AGENCIES ACROSS THE NATION, I
HAVE FAITH IN OUR OFFICERS, I
HAVE FAITH IN THE FBI AND DID A
GREAT JOB.
BUT, SURE, THERE WAS SOME TIMES
EVEN THROUGHOUT THE DAY THAT WE
WERE ALWAYS CONCERNED.
>> HI, CHIEF, DANIA BACA, CBS
NEWS, YOU COULD TALK ABOUT THE
CONNECTION TO PENNSYLVANIA.
>> ALL I KNOW IS THAT HE LIVES
IN PENNSYLVANIA.
>> CHIEF, GUY TANNENBAUM FROM
SPOKANE.
MORE ABOUT THE ELANTRA.
YOU MENTIONED THAT YOU RECOVERED
ONE BUT YOU COULD SPECIFY WHERE
THAT WAS FOUND AND WE KNOW THAT
THAT WAS ONE OF THE BIGGEST
PIECES OF INFORMATION YOU WERE
ASKING FROM THE PUBLIC TO TIP.
WERE YOU ABLE TO PROVIDE
INFORMATION ON WHETHER THOSE
TIPS LEAD TO THE SEIZURE OF AN
ELANTRA.
>> THAT IS STILL PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WILL COME OUT
IN THE FUTURE.
>> CHIEF, GLENN MOSELEY, IDAHO
PUBLIC RADIO HERE IN MOSCOW.
THE ADDITIONAL POLICE PRESENCE
THERE TOWN AND ON CAMPUS,
SEMESTER IS COMING, IS THAT
GOING TO CONTINUE?
>> YOU WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
STATE TROOPERS IN THE AREA,
WE'RE TALKING TO LATA COUNTY AS
WELL.
YOU WILL SEE A PRESENCE OF US
THAT WE'RE ALWAYS HAVE UP ON
CAMPUS.
WE HAVE ASSIGNED OFFICERS TO
THAT SO YOU WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
A LAW ENFORCEMENT PRESENCE.
>> I'M GOING TO TAKE TWO MORE
QUESTIONS.
>> HI, CHIEF, JULIE SCOTT, ABC
NEWS.
COULD YOU TELL US IF YOU
EVENTUALLY HAD A LICENSE PLATE
NUMBER TO THE ELANTRA, AND HOW
YOU TRACKED IT TO PULLMAN?
>> THAT IS STILL PART OF THE
INVESTIGATION.
THAT WILL COME OUT.
>> CHIEF, HI, MATT LOVELESS WITH
THE MURAL COLLEGE OF EDUCATION.
I WANT TO ASK ABOUT MR.
COEBERGER AND YOU ARE AWARE THAT
IF HE RETURNED TO CAMPUS AFTER
NOVEMBER 13th AND HAVE YOU HAD
ANY COMMUNICATION ABOUT HIS
ATTENDANCE?
>> SO, SOME OF THAT IS GOING TO
BE FOLLOWED UP AS WE CONTINUE
OUR INVESTIGATION.
AND WE'LL BE ASKING SOME OF
THOSE QUESTIONS.
SO I WANT TO THANK YOU ALL.
YOU REALLY HAVE BEEN THE
NATIONAL VOICE FOR US.
YOU'VE GIVEN UP THE OPPORTUNITY
TO GET MANY, MANY TIPS AND I DO
APPRECIATE EVERYTHING THAT
YOU'VE